wie groß kann der charta eines vulkans
eigentlich werden der supervulkan
probezeit wie groß 100 km lang und 30
kilometer breite und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er oder ein
anderer supervulkan noch in diesem
jahrhundert ausbrechen und eine riesige
katastrophe auf die erde bringen ist
hoch und die vorwarnzeit dafür extrem
kurz fliegt vom science fiction herzlich
willkommen es ist unvermeidlich der
nächste super bekam wird ausbrechen und
es wird schlimmer folgen haben der
himmel wird sich verdunkeln eine ab
nuklearer winter wird ausbrechen wird
einige kraft kälte auf der erde
millionen tote hungersnöte
völkerwanderung ja das alles wenn die
folgen seien bei einem der letzten male
vor 74.000 jahren als der grube
ausgebrochen ist hat es vermutlich fast
die gesamte menschheit vernichtet das
waren noch nicht viele aber zeigt die
dramatischen folgen eines solchen
ausbruchs forscher der jackass zur zeit
die auflagen sehen die chancen bei 16
das noch dieses jahrhunderts ein
supervulkan ausbricht genau ist ein
solcher ausbruch nicht vorherzusagen
aber dass er kommt ist sicher nur wann
weiß keiner
einer der kandidaten ist wiederum der
toba forscher der universitäten 07 näher
untersucht und beunruhigendes unter
seiner karriere also quasi den krater
gefunden unter dem vulkan schiebt sich
der grund eines indonesischen ozean
unter indonesien 100 kilometer unter der
erde wird dann das wasser aus dieser
erst platte gerückt und bringt dadurch
das gestein darüber zu schnellten
manchmal entsteht 50.000 kubikmeter
schlummern dort inzwischen in 30 bis 50
kilometern tiefe darüber etwas was die
katastrophe es möglich macht eingespannt
decke setzt das magma wie ein
dampfkochtopf unter immensen druck und
was noch schlimmer macht gas im magma
das den druck noch weiter es ist
irgendwann bricht der gesteins decke
unter dem druck durch es kommt zur mega
fc st
aber wann das geschieht kann niemand
sagen mach ma band sich seitlich stoß
artig umbaus dann über jahrzehnte den
druck auf aber davon bekommt man einer
oberfläche nicht erst ein jahr vorher
kündigt ich wohl ein solcher ausbruch
anders haben wo die hamburger von der
vanderbilt university und diesen fakten
von der university of chicago bei den
usa herausgefunden
sie schauten sich kristalle aus dem
aufbruch
bekannt im long valley an mehr als die
hälfte der kristalle braucht nicht jahre
und gewachsen dollar wesentlich ein paar
tage die kristalle entstehen vor dem
ausbruch wenn das geschmolzene gestein
an quaas über 60 ist und es deshalb aus
was geschieht wenn das gas aus dem magma
ausdrückt und sich damit die
zusammensetzung des magmas ändert wenn
die kristalle aber so schnell wachsen
dann heißt das dass auch das erst kurz
vor dem ausbruch austritt und an der
erdoberfläche verstärkt beobachtet
werden kann dass sich zwei drittel 6
halle im fall kommt von einem jahr
auskristallisiert hätten gehen die
forscher von einer vorwarnzeit von
lediglich einem jahr trotz der widrigen
bedingungen unter dem turbo superpokal
gegen die wissenschaftler nicht von
einem ausbruch in der nächsten falls aus
aber ein anderer supervulkan könnte
ausbrechen welcher und wo niemand weiß
es denn über die anderen supervulkan
weiß die wissenschaft weitaus weniger es
wird also dann eine unangenehme
überraschung ja und mehr spannende
wirklich auf videos gibt es in der best
aufstieg zum playlist dafür auf jeden
fall drauf klicken und wenn er in
zukunft nicht verpassen wollen drückt
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht mehr einen song auf die glocke zu
geben bis dann bleibt